ces deux hommes sont artistes sculpteurs
l'on travaille le fer jean-luc tout sans
l'autre lapierre frais sous ce nom at
aux baronnies et des mexicains en
martinique pour encore un mois
invité dans l'association culturel
léopold j'ai rencontré le ray soudah
haut dans sa ville natale qui s'appelle
metepec et il m'a prêté son atelier pour
travailler et tous les jours comme je
suis resté un mois et demi tous les
jours j'ai j'ai mangé dans sa famille
j'ai vécu de sa famille c'est comme ça
que j'ai connu et on est devenus amis
comme ça et donc voilà je lui rends la
pareille je lui ai dit écoute si tu veux
venir si tu veux découvrir la martinique
créé sous snow nato baronne est venu
défier la pierre volcanique de la
martinique une matière très dur couple
un stand as-safir par 4-3 en général si
travailler le marbre la matière
organique très agressive
le mauvais très souple mon outil rentrer
à l'intérieur tandis que la période à
mick explose ce que je travaille
il y à des éclats qui peuvent être un
artiste de renom au mexique connu pour
ses oeuvres très imposante il travaille
le marois mais aussi le bois et le
bronze notamment que sous snow la taupe
aaron va exposer trois de ses oeuvres à
fort de france le 22 juin à la galerie
colette mi-mars plusieurs rendez vous
avec d'autres artistes martiniquais
particulièrement des jeunes en formation
avant de quitter la martinique le 5
juillet prochain
[Musique]